I was out here at the Eastern pad  it's 50 miles east from where we found  him hey boy do you know where your  parents are your family I guess he was  on a picnic or camping trip he wandered  off got himself lost I've been out in  the woods doing things his own way  sounds like a boy after your own heart  how long has she been out there six  years nobody could survive in that force  for six years at least not alone you'll  see I haveli who's Elliot  you need to get back  he gets carried on  is elliot person no it looks like a  dragon what's a dragon Shh that's a  dragon you don't have to run anymore  paint you can stay with us this thing is  dangerous so don't believe you come  looking for you what's gonna happen to  Elliot you have no idea what this thing  is capable of let's go honey  you're very brave did you you might be  the bravest boy I've ever met  attention all units work eastbound  Millhaven road and pursued a dragon it's  a dragon you can't play dragon over the  radio